[Music]
hello again time then for the press
preview we're taking first look what is
on the front pages of tomorrow's papers
checking out the headlines tonight with
huff uk's political editor kevin
schofield and the director of
communications at the institute of
economic affairs annabelle denham
they'll be with us from now until just
before midnight very good evening to
both of you we'll chat in a moment after
we've had a look at those front pages
for you starting with the i which is
that some cabinet members are poised to
revolt over what they regard as the
prime minister and chancellor's lack of
a long-term plan for how to deal with
the cost of living crisis
indeed a poll carried out by the daily
mail suggests the conservatives could
lose the next election if they don't
properly address the issue
the mirror highlights the presence of
rishi sunak and his wife on the sunday
times rich list
the personal finances of the sunak
household are also the main concern for
the star
let's bring in the ft it's got word of a
plunging u.s stock market thanks largely
to the impact of inflation
according to the guardian police chiefs
are likely to apologize for historic
racism among their forces but will steer
clear of admitting it was institutional
foreign secretary liz truss has told the
daily telegraph that nato may arm
moldova in an effort to put an end to
russia's advance in the region
the times reports on possible upcoming
strike action by members of the rmt rail
union
saturday's express understands at least
one member of the royal family is
housing refugees from ukraine
while the sun has a story bringing new
meaning to british ukrainian relations
and a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen join the
program you can check out the front
pages of the papers while you watch and
listen to us and as i say i'm joined
tonight by kevin schofield and annabelle
denham great to see you both so lots to
discuss and uh uh lots to talk about
when it comes to the cost of living
crisis and the economy why don't we
start with the front page of the daily
mail annabelle they've done a poll
revealing uh the toll of soaring prices
and say that it delivers a stark warning
to the prime minister this is looking
ahead to any potential general
election yes this is the poll that's
warning boris that he really needs to
get a grip on the rising cost of living
and it really underscores that it is
still the economy stupid when it comes
to
uh general elections if people feel that
they are getting poorer it is very
difficult for the government to remain
in power if they feel like they're
getting richer then perhaps things like
party gate can be more easily
forgiven and of course people are are
worried um we're seeing this rising cost
of living i think there's an expectation
that things are going to get quite a bit
worse before they get better with the
bank of england itself predicting that
inflation could um exceed double digits
towards the end of this year and that's
ultimately being reflected not just in
the polls but in people's behavior too
as the daily mail points out
uh the public are making changes to
their daily lives to save money um so
the tories really are in quite a
perilous situation they have previously
won elections based on being a safe pair
of hands um for the economy whereas now
they're presiding over you know this
real cost of living catastrophe um to
such an extent that you now have some
members of parliament conservative
members of parliament reportedly
whispering that the best thing for the
party might be to lose in 2024 to to
regroup and to come back into power at
the general election after that that's
how bad people are potentially expecting
the situation
uh to get and all we're seeing really is
this on off policy making very
short-termist measures being introduced
and a lot of indecision that i know
we'll be talking about uh later when it
comes to the cover of the eye
yeah previous governor the bank of
england telling sky news today lord king
uh that there is a very unpleasant
period ahead uh it sort of brings us on
kevin to the front of the eye in terms
of what are we going to do about it
johnson and sunak
face new cabinet mutiny over the uh cost
of living
we have heard haven't we in recent days
that there is there is a split on how to
solve this crisis
yeah and we're told that
advisers to boris johnson um are
advising against a windfall tax and
despite the fact that it is incredibly
popular i mean clearly putting up taxes
isn't a very conservative thing to do
however um the conservative mps i speak
to on the right and left of the party
are all pretty much in agreement that
something needs to be done and the
windfall tax seems the obvious way way
to do it they say that the profits that
the energy companies are making the oil
and gas companies are making through
nothing more than them benefiting from
the global spike in energy prices means
that they are ripe for a fresh tax i
don't think the public would mind it one
little bit if that money was plowed into
bringing down their own bills and i
think mps are frustrated they want
the chancellor and the prime minister to
come up with something because right now
there's nothing fresh on the table we
know that um they announced uh nine
billion pounds worth of help with energy
bills and council tax bills in february
but that's that's already been banked
that's gone now
and people can't wait until the autumn
to the next budget or because when the
energy price cap goes up again in
october bills are going to go up again
so people are really struggling now
and it's not just a case of
when rather than if the government does
something um in the interim to help
people get over the next few months but
as you say the there is a split
uh within government as to what that
should be
and until they can come together and
agree on something i think the
conservatives are going to languish and
behind labor in the polls yeah um quite
a few papers annabelle going with rishi
sunak's personal finances including the
front of the mirror uh the fat cat
chancellor they call him rishi's riches
i mean how fair is it um
to to to pinpoint uh rishi sunak's
personal uh wealth is is it is it fair
cop do you think
um i mean i can't personally see why
this is on the cover of a few newspapers
aside from our obsession with with
gotcha journalism or the obsession we've
got to donate
among some outlets uh at the moment and
you know you have the gmb's gavin thorpe
saying we can't trust this
multi-millionaire to to help us and i
think that really underscores the
the level of distrust that we we seem to
have of wealth in uh britain today it's
not something that's to be uh celebrated
or commended in the way that you get in
the u.s but rather something that that
some people view with with a degree of
skepticism uh my view i'm popular that
may be is that it's good that our senior
politicians can perhaps appreciate the
impact that higher taxes have on on the
wealthy rather than this assumption that
we can just continue to pile
taxes on them without any changes to
their decision making or to their
financial position and we we have to be
aware when when it comes to raising
taxes that they do have unintended
consequences they do alter people's
behaviors if you uh increase uh income
tax at the top level for instance you
might see people reducing their hours or
retiring earlier and you need to ask
whether that is uh to our economic
benefit
over the medium to to longer term
okay i just want to bring in uh the
inside pages of the times pages six and
seven that picture of
rishi sunak and his wife there but when
it comes to partygate this is what the
times are going with sue grey plans to
publish downing street messages
about parties and tonight sam coats has
had an exclusive
kevin saying that um the prime minister
met with sue gray around about a month
ago to discuss that report what
what's going on here what do you make of
it
well i can understand why people might
be
a little bit alarmed uh i mean it's a
great scoop first of all hats off to sam
coats for forgetting the story i mean
people are going to think well
is this a whitewash coming you know um
the premise has already
in many people's eyes got off the hook
as far as the met are concerned only
been fined for for one relatively minor
party despite the fact that he was that
many of them that other people were
fined for attending um now i think it
may well be a little bit unfair i think
anyone who read sugree's interim report
um at the end of january would struggle
to argue that she's anything other than
completely impartial and fair that was
highly critical i think everyone's
expecting her full report when it comes
out we hope next week to be equally if
not more damaging for the government um
it may well be this was just a normal
bit of process uh the prime minister she
is at the end of the day
either way
though it does raise eyebrows doesn't it
i mean why would she need a meeting uh
in the first place you think that uh uh
sort of administrative people would be
able to sort of uh dot in the eyes
across any teas or whatever why does she
actually need to meet the prime minister
but even if it was above board the
optics are terrible
no i agree it looks bad and unless and
you know if there's any suspicion that
the
uh report has been watered down in any
way when we get to see it and people are
going to point at this meeting and say
well hang on a minute uh you had this
meeting with the prime minister and all
of a sudden you've
drawn your horns and a little bit when
it comes to the report i think we might
have to just
wait and see and reserve judgment until
we see the report if indeed it is not as
critical as we expected to be then maybe
then you could ask well hang on a minute
why did the prime minister who is
ultimately sue gray's boss remember so
he does have the power i guess to to to
haul her in if he wants to talk to her
but yeah i agree it looks bad and i
think i think we started to see what the
report says before we decide whether it
was bad yeah okay we're gonna have to go
to a break but annabelle we'll get your
thoughts uh on that story uh after uh
eleven o'clock but uh i think pretty
much everyone uh that spoken to sam
coats uh who's concerned with that
meeting says that it wasn't about her
judgment into partygate it was more
about the uh uh how the police
investigation was being handled but we
will discuss that again uh in a few
minutes time uh meanwhile coming up the
foreign secretary weighs in as concern
mounts over a possible russian incursion
into moldova we'll discuss that next
[Music]
hello again part two of the press
preview kevin and annabelle are still
with us annabelle front of saturday's
telegraph uh the foreign secretary
saying we'll give moldova weapons to
stop president putin
yes quite a wide-ranging interview i
think with the foreign secretary but
they've uh sort of focused on uh liz
trust disclosing that she wants to send
modern referee to
moldova which borders ukraine to the
south west and the fears are that it
could be vladimir putin's next
territorial target so preemptive action
in that respect um it would see a
replacement of moldova's soviet-era
military equipment and soldiers would be
trained on how to use it of course this
would be quite a significant expansion
in the uk's military support in the
region um i think the wider point has to
be made that
vladimir putin had hoped that his war on
ukraine would deter further nato
expansion and
neutralize its influence it would stoke
divisions uh among the western alliance
and you know talk about a plan back
firing the the opposite has happened it
has happened and this news today or that
will be on the cover of the telegraph uh
tomorrow
is coming off the back of course of
the development that sweden and finland
have formally submitted their
applications to join nato so a real
strengthening of of the alliance there
and a change in attitudes among
uh some western partners yeah
interesting to see that boris johnson
had a phone call with the president of
uh turkey kevin uh tonight because we
know turkey have uh uh uh have raised a
few questions haven't they about that
expansion of nato
yeah i mean i i don't think given that
they are an and nato member but yeah i
mean it's important i mean the the boris
johnson is uh he wants to be seen as
leading the the western um alliance
essentially against vladimir putin um so
yeah he's been having lots of these
calls uh and yeah it would be
interesting i think to just to be flying
the wall of that particular one because
obviously there's a lot of persuading to
do there are concerns uh certainly from
a russian point of view about the
expansion of nato annabelle's absolutely
correct the the whole point of going
into ukraine was to prevent that from
happening so it's completely blown up
and vladimir putin's face there's one
other thing i just wanted to mention in
the leicester's interview she doesn't
just talk about ukraine she mentions the
fact that if there was another brexit
referendum she would vote
leave she voted remain the first time
and she also talks about being a tax
cutting conservative which i think shows
you that you know for all that boris
johnson's managed to get through
partygate um his position is not uh
secure
by any means and there are those
likeliest trusts who are obviously still
looking to um endear themselves to
conservative mps should a vacancy arise
yeah interesting goes back to what we
were talking about earlier and very
quickly just want to show the front of
the daily express royal family secretly
house refugees the frustrating thing
sometimes about doing the press preview
is we get the front pages but we don't
get the detail it says you've got to
turn to page three where we might find
out who it is um edward and sophie maybe
princess anne uh did the refugees hit
the jackpot and get wills and kate i
wonder we shall maybe find out a little
bit later we'll investigate further
thank you both very much for the moment
we shall speak again
in a few minutes time